more than 2 million fans have heard
musician Billy Joel at world-famous
Madison Square Garden the piano man
played his 100th concert at the venue
last night
[Music]
where the concert met you know all the
words Joel started his current residency
and January 2014 and holds the record
for the most consecutive performances by
any artist at MSG Anthony Mason spoke
with Billy Joel yesterday in an
interview for CBS Sunday morning
ahead of the historic night Anthony good
morning to you love you good morning
Billy Joel graced the stage of the
garden last night with surprise guest
Bruce Springsteen his 100th show marked
one of the most significant achievements
in his already extraordinary career it
was Joel's fifty fourth consecutive
sold-out show in this residency we spoke
to him about what this milestone means
to him as the hundredth show different
in any way for you it's a landmark date
a hundred shows yeah I'm wondering is
everything else getting climactic ft to
do 100 shows but yes we've already sold
shows past this one yeah so we're in
like a hundred five hundred six now
you've gone on and they're basically
giving you the keys to the place yeah I
thought it would really start to drop
off I thought maybe a year maybe a
little more than a year and it would be
kind of an art to it and it would tend
to dissipate yeah now the tickets are
selling faster than at the beginning so
I may be doing this for the rest of my
natural life but I'm not complaining
it's the best job I ever had the garden
announced yesterday that Joel's piano
will now be on display at the venue to
honor his remarkable achievement and
Governor Andrew Cuomo proclaimed July
18th yesterday Billy Joel day in the
state of New York so you were there what
was it like it was you know Billy Joel
has a way of making Madison Square
Garden feel intimate 20,000 people feels
like really like a couple of thousand
which is an extraordinary man that is
not an easy place to play it really is
it yeah Ryan called it the comfort food
of concerts is that a good I thought
that was a good description well you can
imagine the sound when Bruce Springsteen
walked on the same yeah yeah it's like
if you're from this part of the world
your head explodes you know I mean I saw
I saw Bruce for the first time in 1973
at the garden opening for Chicago I saw
Billy the next year for the first time
at the cellar door in Georgetown when I
was in college both of those guys at
that time there
they were in the same label which was
about to drop both of them because they
weren't selling records yeah and then
all of a sudden Born to Run comes out
Bruce life changes the next year
stranger comes out Billy's life changes
and here we are one's on Broadway and
guess you didn't need a plus-one you
lost my number you should have called
mr. K drew thank you thank you okay well
you'll work that out after the show no
bitterness here you can watch Anthony's
full interview with Billy Joel this
Sunday on CBS Sunday morning